rassemblement soutient olivier dubois ce
mardi sur la place de la république à
paris
une initiative de l'omg et reporters
sans frontières alors que le
correspondant de libération le point
jeune afrique au mali a été pris en
otage par un groupe djihadiste affiliés
à al qaïda il ya tout juste deux mois à
la famille les amis le comité de soutien
à olivier dubois réclame la libération
du journaliste depuis son enlèvement
olivier dubois est apparu brièvement
dans une vidéo le 4 mai dernier
indiquant avoir été enlevé nous sommes
là pour soutenir olivier en fait nous
sommes vraiment là pour lui qu'importe
finalement de notre état d'esprit à nous
tout ce que nous faisons en off est
vraiment pour l'aider au quotidien voilà
et surtout pour deux au vrai pour sa
libération c'est vraiment ça qui compte
notre espoir le plus cher se serait que
olivier peut-être puisse entendre un de
ces messages
on sait de la bouche d'anciens otages
qui a parfois des messages qui peuvent
leur parvenir via des radios des télés
africaine il ya airs et filles à france
donc aujourd'hui on a voulu concentrer
un maximum de messages de proches pour
que peut-être l'un d'entre eux puisse y
parvenir dans la solitude qui est celle
d'un otage
aux mains de ses ravisseurs c'est vrai
que d'avoir un contact avec le monde
extérieur est une des choses
primordiales
c'est à dire qu on a vraiment
l'impression d'être au fond de lui que
tout le monde vous a oublié que vous
n'êtes plus en contact avec personne
avec le pays d'origine avec souvent
on est dans cette situation là et savoir
qu'on pense à vous pouvoir avoir un
message pouvoir dire ils sont là ils ne
m'oublie pas c'est quelque chose de
primordial c'est pour ça qu'on est ici
aujourd'hui